more than a thousand climate change
activists were arrested over Easter
calling for a major action to cut carbon
emissions and it seems that some
politicians or might be listening
because today Labour announced plans to
force a vote in Parliament on Wednesday
which would make the UK the first
country in the world to declare a
climate emergency so joining us now from
Salford is the shadow business secretary
Rebecca long Bailey thank you very much
for being on the program today morning
Sophie
quite refreshing to start on a subject
that isn't brexit related labour this
morning calling for a climate emergency
to be described now is that just you
know an eye-catching phrase or does it
actually mean anything what would be the
first Parliament in the world to declare
such a climb in an environment emergency
but that's the first step in a long list
of radical action that we want the
government to take we want them to take
action that's commensurate with this
national emergency and in doing so not
just provide a better quality of life
for people here and across the world
were also unlock the huge economic
benefits that back in a green industrial
revolution which is what the Labour
Party's been pushing for for some time
and the economic benefit that that will
bring to many of our communities right
across the UK through to manufacturing
all the way through to energy efficiency
measures because what I'm interested in
trying to find out is what this actually
entails because it's easy to kind of
talk in these grandiose terms about
climate emergencies but it's much more
difficult to take they're quite
challenging decisions that need to
happen in order to bring as Labour wants
to see carbon emissions down to Net Zero
by 2050 so for example are you looking
at things like the expansion of Heathrow
Airport and does labour back that well
it is I mean it's quite dramatic making
this assertion on on Wednesday declaring
a national emergency in relation to
climate an environment but it's
necessary because we know from everybody
from the Met Office to NASA to the
Intergovernmental Panel on Climate
Change as stated that if we don't take
radical action across the world not just
here in the UK we're not going to be
able to reverse the damaging effects of
climate change and we've got to bring
our emissions down by 45 percent
compared to 2010 levels by 2030
reach NetZero by 2050 and that requires
a national emergency a mission if you
like to unlock public investment but
also private investment so get everybody
in the UK behind this challenge and
we've been looking at a range of options
a green industrial revolution is the
term that I mentioned earlier and that's
everything from supporting low-carbon
and renewable energy technologies such
as solar onshore and offshore wind home
energy efficiency programs supporting
direct public and private investment in
new transport technology such as
electric and hydrogen powered vehicles
and unfortunately at the moment here in
the UK was not simply not doing an offer
reduced our emissions by 2 percent in
the last year we're not anywhere near
meeting our carbon budgets the fourth
and fifth carbon budget so the level of
action that's required is huge and we
will need to see significant public
support and public investment in this
but it's not just in terms of public
investment that direct investment it's
looking at the other policy levers that
we can use the incentivization to spur
on our businesses to become more
sustainable through tax incentives and
all those subsidies looking at the
creation of a market for new technology
such as electric vehicles using policy
levers such as procurements to make sure
that our public bodies procure electric
vehicles where possible there are many
simple things that we can do and there
are many complicated things that we can
do but what's clear is very very simple
we have to take this dramatic action now
because if we don't were going to see
irreversible damage to our environment
and our quality of life not just here in
the UK but right across the world ok no
mention there of ether expansion which
was what the question was actually about
and I wonder what expansion don't let me
come back to that point it's as if
Heathrow expansion we were clear when
the debate went through Parliament that
the Labour Party thought that the
expansion of Heathrow Airport didn't
meet many of the objectives that we've
set out in relation to climate change
the evidence hasn't changed since then
and we remain skeptical for what we want
to see is significant investment and
public action and governmental action in
relation to sectors such as aviation
shipping the transport sector to bring
emissions down but that will only happen
that development that research and
development those new technologies with
a real government incentive and drive
behind it ok another difficult decision
if you like radical action that would
help cut carbon emissions is fracking
and the government's fracking czar quit
today saying they're actually the policy
is being guided by fear mongering rather
than science would labor support
fracking as one of these difficult
decisions to try and bring carbon
emissions down which is what you want to
see we want to ban fracking we don't
think that it's responsible for a
government to lock the UK into another
fossil fuel industry quite frankly aside
from the other you know air quality
concerns that many communities have
their potential for earth tremors etc
etc the list is endless the overturning
of local democracy because many councils
let's remember a voted against having
fracking in their areas yet they've been
ignored by government but we just don't
think it's responsible to lockers into
that fossil fuel related future at a
time when we should be throwing our
weight behind low-carbon and renewable
technologies ok and one of the reasons
that we're talking about an environment
in a minute is because of the protesters
the extreme rebellion protesters who
have ground the capital to a halt with
some of their demonstrations now your
colleague Barry Gardner liken them to
the suffragettes and the Chartists I'm
wondering where you are in relation to
the protester is a day just an annoyance
for commuters or they the modern-day
suffragettes no I mean the climate
change protesters extinction rebellion
and the schoolchildren who've been on
strike recently they represent a whole
cross-section of British society and
let's remember in the last week you know
we had an unprecedented day where we saw
a statement on climate change from the
Environment and Energy Minister and we
also saw an urgent question on climate
change at a time when the whole debate
in Parliament has been dominated solely
by brexit so they've spurred on
politicians and people right across
society to start dealing with this issue
and to consider it as an emerging
see and I think that it's great that if
anybody wants to raise this issue
politically within their community they
should do so because it really is a
national emergency and that's the whole
point of us having this debate next week
to make sure that we declare a national
climate and environment emergency okay
now I did certain beginning the show
that it was refreshing to talk about
things other than brakes they've been
given the fact that you are one of a
very select group of people in these
cross-party bricks that talks along with
the shallow bricks that secretary kissed
armor and jeremy corbyn i do want to ask
you how it's going because conservative
sources have been saying to us that
labor is dragging its heels that you're
not serious about trying to get a deal
across the line that would mean the
European elections didn't need to happen
I mean how are the talks going well
we're certainly not dragging our heels
by any stretch of anybody's imagination
and I have to say honestly I think the
discussions so far I've been productive
we've gone into a lot of detail there
seems to be a willingness on both sides
to move towards some form of consensus
but as yet we haven't seen the
government move on any of their red
lines but we're having further
discussions this week and hopefully
we'll see some movement but at the
moment we are focusing on the detail
where we stand in relation to our
relevant positions and where potentially
we could move to what we want to see
hard and fast movement on those red
lines as quickly as possible I mean
you're saying that the government isn't
moving on its red line so what are
Labour's red lines and where are you
prepared to compromise so really really
specifically if you could be as crystal
clear as you could is a second
referendum a red line for labor in these
talks
well I wouldn't couch it in terms of a
second referendum but our party policy
has always been that firstly we want to
get a brexit deal that puts our economy
and living standards first and protects
you know our environmental protections
workplace protections health and safety
standards we want a customs union
arrangement in order to keep our borders
open so that our manufacturing industry
isn't detrimental E affected and we keep
that the movement of goods as freely
flowing as possible and we want a strong
single market relationship now we're not
being hugely prescriptive
on the my new detail of specific
elements because we are willing to be
compromising we're willing to be
flexible and we've reiterated that
numerous times to the government and
there has been movement in certain areas
we've been having fantastic discussions
and workers rights for example though
the government seems quite amenable to
moving towards certainly what I've been
asking for but we're waiting to see at
the moment whether that turns in depends
on paper on in terms of legislation and
real hard fast entrenchment provisions
but we have been having productive
discussions and I'm hopeful that over
the coming weeks that we will see some
movement and certainly that's the
intention that I'm going into the
discussions with and indeed the Labour
colleagues that are sitting with me so
in listening to your answer there if you
got what you wanted on a customs union
and a close relationship with the single
market will lady be prepared to sign off
that deal if it wasn't put back to the
public again what we've said in terms of
the policy that was set out at our
conference last year was that to avoid
damaging Tory Brennan from last year
haven't they we're talking about the
cross party talks that happening now
well at Malta in order to be happy with
the deal it would have to satisfy what
the Labour Party has been trying to
achieve in terms of that close economic
relationship that close collaboration
with Europe that no wonder mining of
environment climate change health and
safety standards workers rights etc etc
and that's what we're trying to move
towards in terms of our deal but if we
don't get a deal that satisfies those
objectives it's a damaging deal of
damaging Tory brexit deal or there's a
risk of was moving towards a no deal in
that circumstance we've said that all
options should be on the table and that
includes campaigning for a public vote
but our priority in these negotiations
is to find a consensus and to get a deal
that we know will protect the economy so
it sounds like to me a second referendum
is not a redline for labour in the talks
I mean correct me if I'm wrong well it's
well it no it's a public vote in the
event of the situation that I've just
outlined has always been our party
policy now we have to be flexible in
where we move on we've got to keep all
options on the table and that's what
we're doing so until we find out what
the final deal will be
we are of course pushing you know the
government to consider you know that the
policy option that we have which is a
public vote in order to avoid damaging
No Deal brexit or a bad deal and they're
considering that and the how I haven't
come back with any confirmation as to as
to whether they'll move on that red line
as it haven't with a number of their
other red lines but certainly we're
outlining our party policy very very
clearly okay now we've got the local
elections looming next week what would
be a good performance by the Labor Party
well I think it would be naive of me to
not think that brexit would play a big
part in our local election certainly
from the feedback that I'm getting on
the doorstep in my constituency many of
I residents are talking about brexit on
the doorstep as well as all of the other
issues that affect their lives in
relation to living standards and
austerity and and to think that that
wouldn't have an effect on people's
voting intentions I think would be as I
say naive and we've also got to remember
that the last situation that were in
when we saw such large-scale local
lectures was 2015 at the time of a
general election where turnout was a lot
higher so I couldn't you know without a
crystal ball you know state what I think
the outcome of those elections was going
to be certainly from from the doorsteps
that I've been on there have been
discussions about brexit but ultimately
a lot of our labor support is still
there and they're still quite positive
about our domestic policy agenda and
certainly the agenda that our local
councils are setting out to try and
limit the damage that this Conservative
government is doing to our local
communities and I hope that people
certainly bear that in mind when they're
going to the ballot box in the local
elections now and before I let you go I
just want to talk about you for one
second because you're clearly in the
leaders circle of trust you're one of
the few people in these brexit talk so
we know that you all know spoken of as
someone who's close to John MacDonald as
well you talked about often as a future
leader of the Labour Party so do you
think you'd make a good Prime Minister
well I think it's it's a bit absurd and
crazy to be talking about things like
that whenever we're going to read things
like that in the press it does make me
chuckle a bit and certainly my priority
and the priority of the whole Shadow
Cabinet is to
a Labour government elected under Jeremy
Corbyn with him being our Prime Minister
that's what we're all working towards
and we're all playing out the PR that's
a PR on it that's the PR answer I
understand but what do you think you'd
make a good Prime Minister it's not
something I'm not really did a little
bit I'll be totally honest but it's not
something that I've ever considered or
would consider anytime soon